[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
la la la you ready big guy yeah I'm like
totally ready everyone in the city gets
a shot at being a storm in our thinking
competition this thanks is about to
explode with major Big E power don't
Humpty you're really funny looking
that's all I got I get things cooking
come on Lady
how come my lady you're my butterfly
sugar baby oh my gosh look at her butt
oh my gosh look at her are you okay oh
yes I'm fine thank you how are you if
you want to become stars and win a
hundred grand and you better be ready to
work harder than you've ever worked in
your lives
oh yes that was very bed we're strong
there's no Hill where were you I was a
rehearsal but I don't want to be in your
game
I want to be a singer lawyered up with a
son not you music you know and talk to
you
so scared come on be confident don't you
want this I'm back what is going on here
come on me what if reason it only
squeeze in Hobie we consider these
minutes go don't let fear stop you from
doing the thing you love you know what's
great about hitting rock bottom there's
only one way left to go and that is my
son
she's not even that good yeah totally
[Music]
just see
I'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and cue the crazy old lizard good
morning mr. moon I got Judas from the
bank on line two
actually I'm glad to call her back my
theaters been going through some pretty
rough times so what do I do a car wash
no my next show is gonna be drumroll
please a singing competition who wants
to see another one of those everyone
your neighbor the the grocery store
manager that got that chicken right
there
real talent from real life that's what
audience is one and I'm gonna get a tool
do you ever feel feel so paper my mommy
Marmon would you please tell them what a
good singer I am oh yeah you were great
honey by the way the bathroom sink is
blocked again by honey in your mind
could you ever be really close to me
[Applause]
sure you were supposed to be keeping a
lookout sorry dad to you if I had a
voice like Mena's I'd be a superstar by
now just singing oh yeah sure he
wouldn't grandmother now blow out your
candles hmm how we do with those flyers
miss Crawley
this will be the best hit show this city
has ever seen everyone gets a shot at
being a store live on my stage I'm here
win that prize it's mine go home see
you're really funny looking that's
alright cause I get things cooking oh my
gosh look at her butt oh my gosh look at
her are you okay oh yes I'm fine thank
you how are you this is it folks you
better be ready to work harder than
you've ever worked in your lives yes
that was very bad cups of shows a final
design the fire went out a long time ago
you are not gonna believe what I did
today but I don't want to be in your
gang I wanna be a singer how did I end
up with a son bought you
so is not gonna save your theater maybe
it's time to move on you know how much
this means to us just thankss about to
explode with major piggy power you know
what's great about hitting rock bottom
there's only one way left to go and
that's
[Music]
[Music]
DiBiase
it's Bellini in aisle six that was
awesome
they said when I would save the things I
want to say to you were supposed to be
keeping a lookout sorry dad
my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times lately so what do I
do
quit no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please a singing competition
interesting your neighbor
the grocery store manager that that
chicken right there from real life
Mormon would you please tell them what a
good singer I am oh yeah you were great
honey
by the way the bathroom sink is blocked
again I'm here win that prize it's mine
everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a store on my stage come my lady
you're my butterfly sugar baby like the
wind right like oh my gosh look at her
butt
yeah okay oh yes I'm firing thank you
how are you people say you're Humpty
you're really funny looking
with me Wow
[Music]
this show is not gonna save your theater
maybe it's time to just move on come on
you know how much this means to us
you can't just see it you got two shows
a file desire the fire went out a long
time ago you are not gonna believe what
I did today I am lost I am bad I just
don't want to be in the gang
I want to be a singer I end up with a
Sun bug you get you out nine wait I'll
get the money I promise I could really
use some extra piano lessons yes that
was very bad a defining moment in all of
our lives
we're going to be spicy no yeah
[Music]
don't let fear stop you can doing the
thing you love you know what's great
about hitting rock bottom there's only
one way left to go and that's
see
[Music]
[Music]
DiBiase
lady in aisle six that was awesome how
we do with those flyers miss Kraus
[Music]
by KL by Maury by Mickey by Moe by
Nelson by Hannah bite a spy by Casper
hey what do you think
a singing competition just think your
neighbor the the grocery store manager
that that's that chicken right there
everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a store live on my stage the wrong
man call my lady
come come my lady you're my butterfly
[Music]
my gosh at her but oh my gosh
like a wheel Rock ooh okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you how are you I
[Music]
you're a wolf man what it's actually
Maui shapeshifter demigod of the
Windansea hero of men I interrupt it
from the top
you're off men go